>> ON THE BORDER, WHY IS THE
BORDER MORE OVERWHELMED UNDER
YOUR WATCH, MR. PRESIDENT?
>> BECAUSE THERE ARE THREE
COUNTRIES THAT ARE NEVER --
THERE ARE FEWER, FEWER
IMMIGRANTS COMING FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA AND FROM MEXICO.
IT'S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCE.
WHAT'S ON MY WATCH NOW IS
VENEZUELA, CUBA AND NICARAGUA.
AND THE ABILITY TO SEVEN THEM
BACK TO THOSE STATEMENTS -- SEND
THEM BACK TO THOSE STATES IS NOT
RATIONAL.
YOU CAN SEND THEM BACK AND HAVE
THEM WHILE WE'RE WORKING WITH
MEXICO COE AND OTHER COUNTRIES
TO SEE IF WE CAN STOP THE FLOW.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
MARIA: WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HE WAS
SAYING.
THAT WAS PRESIDENT BIDEN ON A
WORD SALAD ATTEMPTING TO DEFEND
THIS WIDE OPEN BORDER AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AS MORE THAN 2
MILLION MIGRANTS HAVE CROSSED
ILLEGALLY THIS FISCAL YEAR.
IN NUMBERS JUST RELEASED BY U.S.
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION,
OVER 200,000 PEOPLE WERE
APPREHENDED JUST IN THE LAST
MONTH WITH UNTOLD MORE THAT GOT
AWAY, UPWARDS OF A MILLION
GOTAWAYS, WE ARE TOLD, TYPICALLY
TRAVEL, FIRST, TO TUCSON,
ARIZONA, AFTER CROSSING THROUGH
TEXAS.
IMMIGRATION HAS BECOME ONE OF
THE TOP ISSUES IN THE ARIZONA
GOVERNOR'S RACE, AND IN THE
LATEST POLL REPUBLICANLY LAKE
HAS A NEARLY 5-POINT LEAD OVER
DEMOCRAT CHALLENGER KATIE TO BE.
AND JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS KARI
LAKE HERSELF.
KARI, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
>> GOOD MORNING, MARIA.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GOTAWAY NUMBERS.
A MILLION HAVE COME IN SINCE JOE
BIDEN TOOK OFFICE, AND THESE ARE
THE MOST DANGEROUS CAN ONES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR
BACKGROUND IS.
THEY COULD BE TERRORISTS,
MURDERERS, AND THEY'RE MOST
LIKELY HARD CORE CRIMINALS.
MARIA: OBVIOUSLY, THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN INTENTIONS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GET
APPREHENDED, SO THEY GET AWAY.
IS IT TRUE THAT MANY OF THEM GO
TO TUCSON?
ARE YOU SEEING THIS IN ARIZONA?
>> THEY GO THROUGH THE TUCSON
SECTOR WHICH REALLY IS MORE THAN
HALF OF OUR STATE BORDER.
AND I I WAS JUST TALKING TO THE
SHERIFF OF ONE COUNTY, MARK
DANILS, AND HE TOLD ME 16,000
ARE COMING THROUGH A MONTH IN
THE TUCSON SECTOR.
JUST LAST WEEK THERE WERE TWO
VEHICLES, TWO OF HIS VEHICLES
DAMAGED BY SMUGGLERS WHO CRASHED
INTO THEM TRYING TO GET AWAY.
AND 350 PEOPLE IN THE COUNTY
HAVE BEEN THE VICTIMS OF PEOPLE
PASSING IN ILLEGALLY, CRIMINALS
COMING IN ILLEGALLY.
THERE HAVE BEEN 350 # VICTIMS OF
CRIME IN SIX MONTHS ALONE.
SO IT IS IMPACTING ARIZONANS
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
MARIA: I KNOW THIS IS ONE OF
YOUR TOP PRIORITIES, TO CLEAN UP
THE BORDER SHOULD YOU WIN IN
NOVEMBER.
I WANTN'T TO POINT OUT WHAT LIZ
CHENEY HAS SAID ABOUT YOU WHEN
SPEAKING AT THIS TEXAS TRIBUNE
CONFERENCE YESTERDAY.
SHE SAYS I'M GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING I CAN TO MAKE SURE
KARI LAKE IS NOT ELECTED.
YOUR REACTION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT MIGHT BE THE BIGGEST,
BEST GIFT I'VE EVER RECEIVED.
I MEAN, THE PEOPLE OF WYOMING
CAN'T STAND HER.
I'M PRETTY MUCH SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE OF ARIZONA DON'T LIKE LIZ
CHENEY.
YOU KNOW, HERE'S THE DEAL,
MARIA.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, THE NEW
REPUBLICAN PARTY, IS THE WATER
OF WE, THE PEOPLE. -- PARTY OF
WE, THE PEOPLE.
IT IS NO LONGER THE PARTY OF
WARMONGERS.
SO LIZ CHENEY SHOULD PROBABLY
TURN HER VOTER REGISTRATION.
TURNINGS OUT SHE REALLY IS A
DEMOCRAT AFTER ALL.
MARIA: LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR
AGENDA.
SHE SAID IT DOES INCLUDE
CAMPAIGNING WITH THE THEM THE
ACCURATES TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
DON'T WIN.
[LAUGHTER]
DEMOCRATS.
TELL ME WHAT YOUR PRIORITIES
ARE, AND THEN I WANT TO GET TO
THE DOBBS RULING AND AND YOUR
THOUGHTS ON ABORTION.
I KNOW WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM YOU
ON THAT SUBJECT, BUT GO LU YOUR
AGENDA.
>> WELL, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
THAT BORDER.
DAY ONE WE'RE GOING TO ISSUE A
DECLARATION OF INVASION, CALL IT
WHAT IT IS, AND WE'RE WINNING TO
GET TROOPS ON THE GROUND AND
STOP PEOPLE FROM COMING OVER,
GIVE REINFORCEMENTS TO OUR
BORDER SHERIFFS AND STOP THIS
MADNESS.
WE JUST HAD THE LARGEST DRUG CAN
BUST IN THE HISTORY OF DRUG
BUSTS IN PHOENIX, ARIZONA, THIS
WEEK, A MILLION FENTANYL PILLS.
THIS IS A POISONING OF AMERICA.
I DON'T EVEN CALL THEM DRUG
OVERDOSE CANS BECAUSE ONE PILL,
ONE-HALF A PILL CAN KILL YOU.
THEY ARE TRYING TO TAKE DOWN
THIS COUNTRY.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK BACK
IN HISTORY AT THE OPIUM WARS AND
SEE THAT THEY BROUGHT DOWN
DYNASTIES WITH DRUGS, AND THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE ATTEMPTING TO DO.
WE HAVE TO TACKLE OUR BORDER.
WE WILL START THAT ON DAY ONE.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO START
WORKING ON THE WORK FORCE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE BY BRINGING IN
VOCATIONAL AND TRADE SKILL
TRAINING INTO OUR HIGH SCHOOLS
IN A BIGGER WAY SO THAT AFTER
TENTH GRADE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
CAN GET SOME REAL TRAINING FOR
THE REAL JOBS THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
THESE TRADE JOBS MAKE, WILL
ALLOW KIDS TO MAKE GOOD MONEY
WHERE THEY CAN ACTUALLY SUPPORT
THEMSELVES.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING THAT INTO
OUR SCHOOLS.
AND WE'RE ALSO GOING TO LOOK AT
OUR LONG-TERM WATER ISSUES.
AS ARIZONA GROWS, WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT WAYS TO BRING WATER INTO
OUR STATE.
AND SO WE ARE LASER FOCUSED ON
SOME OF THESE BIG ISSUES THAT
REALLY IMPACT THE PEOPLE OF
ARIZONA.
MARIA: AN ARIZONA JUDGE LIFTED
THAT INJUNCTION ON THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE 1973 LAW
LEAVING THE STATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO PROSECUTE ABORTION
PROVIDERS.
ARIZONA HAS LIFTED THE
INJUNCTION, AND NOW THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, BRNOVICH, TOUTS A WIN
FOR HIS OFFICE DEFENDING LIFE.
YOUR REACTION.
>> I'M PRO-LIFE.
I'VE NEVER BACKED AWAY FROM THAT
AND NEVER WILL.
I WANT TO PROTECT LIVES, AND I
WANT TO HELP WOMEN.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE
WE ARE GIVING WOMEN THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED.
I'M ALL FOR HEALTH CARE FOR
WOMEN.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TRIED TO
POLITICIZE THIS ISSUE IN SUCH A
DISTURBING WAY.
IT WAS JUST ABOUT A WEEK AGO MY
OPPONENT TRIED TO EQUATE WOMEN
WHO HAVE MISCARRIAGES WITH
ABORTIONS.
AND THAT IS REALLY ALARMING.
AND STACEY ABRAMS SAYING THAT
THE HEARTBEAT IS MAKE BELIEVE ON
AN ULTRASOUND.
THIS IS REALLY SAD WHERE THEY'RE
GOING WITH THIS.
WE WANT TO HELP WOMEN.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SCARY MOMENTS WHEN YOU FIND OUT
YOUR PREGNANT -- AND IT CAN BE
SCARY -- THAT WE'RE THERE WITH
THEM PROVIDING ASSISTANCE IN ANY
WAY POSSIBLE.
BUT MY OPPONENT IS RADICAL WHEN
IT COMES TO ABORTION.
SHE VOTED AGAINST A BILL THAT
WOULD HAVE PROVIDED LIFE-SAVING
TREATMENT TO A BABY WHO SURVIVED
ABORTION, OPTING INSTEAD TO HAVE
THAT BABY DIE ON A COLD MEDICAL
TRAY.
THAT IS RADICAL.
AND THE MEDIA HERE REFUSES TO
ASK HER QUESTIONS ABOUT HER
POSITION ON ABORTION.
SHE IS FOR ABORTION RIGHT UP
UNTIL THE MINUTE OF BIRTH AND
AND EVEN AFTERWARDS.
MARIA: WOW.
>> AND, TO ME, THAT IS INHUMANE
AND IMMORAL.
MARIA: THAT IS EXTRAORDINARY.
I KNOW THAT YOU'VE BEEN WANTING
TO DO A DEBATE WITH HER.
SHE IS REFUSING TO DEBATE YOU.
DO YOU THINK YOU'LL GET A DEBATE
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS?
[LAUGHTER]
>> NO.
I THINK SHE'S DOING THE OLD
BASEMENT BIDEN PLAY, AND SHE'S
HIDING OUT AND RUNNING FROM
REPORTERS.
I'D LOVE TO TALK ABOUT ALL THESE
ISSUES.
WE HAVE MAJOR ISSUES THAT ARE
FACING THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA AND
THIS STATE AS WE GO FORWARD.
WE'RE ABOUT READY TO, I BELIEVE,
MOVE INTO A REALM WHERE WE ARE
ONE OF THE TOP STATES IN THE
COUNTRY, AND THERE'S A LOT OF
ISSUES.
I LOOK AT THIS AS A JOB
INTERVIEW, MARIA.
THE DEBATE IS A JOB INTERVIEW.
THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA ARE THE
HIRING MANAGERS, AND I'M WILLING
TO SIT DOWN AND BE INTERVIEWED.
SHE'S NOT.
WE'VE ACTUALLY TAKEN THE JOB
INTERVIEW ON THE ROAD.
WE'RE DOING FIVE OR SIX MORE
STOPS WHERE IT'S ASK ME
ANYTHING, AND LET'S TAKE THIS
JOB INTERVIEW ON THE ROAD.
PEOPLE ARE SHOWING UP BECAUSE
THEY DO WANT TO KNOW WHERE EACH
OF US STAND ON THESE ISSUES, AND
I'M NOT GOING TO SHY AWAY IF
FROM THEM.
MARIA: IT SEEMS LIKE, FINALLY,
THE MEDIA IS BEGINNING TO COVER
THE BORDER ISSUES WHICH, OF
COURSE, YOU'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FROM DAY ONE AND WE'VE
BEEN REPORTING ON FROM DAY ONE.
I'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER FIVE
TIMES, AND YET WE SEE THEM UPSET
BECAUSE OF MIGRANTS SENT TO
PLACES LIKE MARTHA'S VINEYARD
AND ELSEWHERE.
[LAUGHTER]
I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE A THOUGHT
ON WHAT TO DO WITH THESE ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS COMING IN, AND WHAT
ABOUT SERVING THEM TO THESE BLUE
CITIES?
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> YOU KNOW, I'M NOT, I'M NOT
REALLY FOR THAT, I'LL BE HONEST.
HOWEVER, IT IS MAKING A GREAT
POINT.
AND SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO LAY
THINGS OUT FOR THESE SANCTUARY
CITIES OF WHAT WE'RE REALLY
DEALING WITH.
THEY LOST THEIR MINDS OVER 50 #
ILLEGALS THAT WERE SENT THERE,
AND WE'RE DEALING WITH THOUSANDS
UPON THOUSANDS EVERY MONTH.
SO I DO THINK THE POINT HAS BEEN
MADE.
I'M NOT FOR MOVING PEOPLE AROUND
FURTHER INTO THE COUNTRY.
IT MAKES IT HARDER FOR US TO
MOVE THEM BACK ACROSS THE
BORDER.
MARIA: YEAH.
>> I WOULD, IDEALLY, LIKE TO
LOAD UP BUSES AND SEND THEM BACK
ACROSS THE BORDER.
WE CAN'T TAKE ON 5 MILLION
ILLEGAL IMBRANS, AND YOU KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE ANOTHER 5
MILLION THE NEXT TWO YEARS OR
MORE.
WE CAN'T HANDLE THAT.
MARIA: YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL